keeping it real
lindsay lohan and they crucified me for
it in America they made me seem like
Satan I was a bad person for holding
that Quran famous model Hollywood
actress did she accept Islam I don't
know
trying to connect with the Quran the
verbatim Word of God
we're gonna go ahead and take it to this
clip diagnose the situation and share
some very interesting facts with you
about the Quran you probably didn't know
about and give some suggestions be right
back and they crucified me for it in
America they made me seem like Satan I
was a bad person for holding that Quran
and that and I was so happy to leave and
go back to London after that because I
felt so unsafe in my own country after
this I mean people weren't like horrible
to me and just because this is my belief
if I want if this is something I want to
I want to learn this is my personal my
or well this is not for you to express
if you want to say it keep it to
yourself I'm not looking at what you do
every day maybe you're not doing enough
because you're bored hurting me but I
can't imagine how many people go through
this all the time and that made me feel
like an outsider so I understand why you
know the Turkish people are upset
because they live in a great beautiful
place and I understand why women that
were headscarves are looked at
differently because I felt like that so
when the woman when I was in on tap she
put that headscarf on me I felt really
honored because of that because she went
out of her own way to allow me to be
part of her culture and she didn't have
to do that you know I was a stranger to
her and I merely said I really liked the
color of her headscarf and she gave it
to me and maybe she only has two and she
gave me one there's more to that story
that occurs unless did you know what
because this woman took the time to give
me this
and a part of herself not even knowing
me I'm not taking it off and my first
thought and I and I said to my good
friend about I said but it scares me
because people are going to look at the
headscarf and only talk about that
they're not going to ask the real
questions about why because that's not
interesting it will become headlines
suddenly right you know and it should
Wow interesting you know a person could
have done all of them some of the most
scandalous things out there so what we
know of the Hollywood lifestyle is that
this is a lifestyle that really I mean
we've seen it over and over it just
drains the life the spirit out of a
human being the whole world opens up to
you so you get to experiment and taste
and finding dining and all of the music
and drugs and parties and you're with
the the crowd the a star crowd and life
is good but not so good for a lot of
people because after some time like
everything else it just gets tiring and
gets played out and that's what happened
over and over we seen with Lindsay and
many people so we can first see the
benefit of seeing other people hit a
dead end and then ask ourselves do we
want to also hit a dead end in life and
when she see she has been on in and out
of rehabs she had the money she had the
money she had the status still does but
when the heart you can be bankrupt but
if you're not bankrupt in the soul in
the heart
you're still rich but many class-a
actors will tell you this try everything
and anything but at the end if the heart
is empty your life is empty and that's
why we have today
more people on painkillers than on
nicotine because of the pain in the
heart and this is has me thinking of and
we'll get into the Quran and some of the
facts about it you probably know but it
has me thinking about a verse in the
Quran verbatim word of God where God
Almighty is saying that the one who
turns away from God will have a very
difficult strain life a depressed life
so on the outside the facade of the
house it looks very nice but inside the
human body there's a there's the heart
and truly in the remembrance of the
Creator does that heart find rest now
you can do whatever you want but I'm
just sharing the other side because
there's two sides there's your side and
then there's this side and then you
reflect you reflect on your way the way
you're doing things and what it's
accomplishing for you do you really have
that true peace and happiness or you
reflect when you think wow maybe there's
something to what this man is telling me
what this Quran is telling me what is
being communicated to me something to
think about my friend listen now that is
what Lindsey she experienced all these
things so why would someone want to
crucify her for picking up a book and
reading if she's looking to get
enlightened instead of just going from
one party to the after party to the coke
to the dope to the man to the drama
drama and all of the other heartbreak
that this woman has experienced and many
of you probably didn't know I mean for
every hater out there there is an
optimist there are good people who will
not crucify someone for picking up the
Word of God and this is this is
something very interesting that it's
just another proof of our proof that you
know when you have the truth there is
going to be great opposition against you
and you know Wayne Dyer once said this
is a thinker a person who had a very
powerful quote he said the greatest form
of ignorance is to reject something you
know nothing about so it just compounded
ignorance on top of ignorance because
some people say no no we know about
Islam but you don't know because let me
give you an example if you use sitting
at a table and you are talking about
Jack you never met Jack but everybody at
the tables talking about Jack
all of this gossip and all these
negative things they never ate with Jack
they never sat with Jack they never got
to know Jack what does that tell you
they don't know jack yep excuse my
language so you don't know Islam you
don't know the Koran but this woman is
trying to get to know the Koran she's
trying to get to know Islam from the
Muslims so why do you have a problem is
this just something inside of yourself
you got to think about that because you
can't give something you don't have so
if you don't have love how you gonna
give love but if you have hate you can't
give benjamin's if you don't have them
so you're giving something else that you
do have something that's projecting from
inside of you outside of you to outside
of is that hate so leave the woman alone
Lindsey ignore the haters they've hated
when you were making movies they're
gonna continue to hate even more when
you're leaving them behind
you're leaving everybody else back in
the nightclubs on painkillers and you're
like I don't want to have that kind of
lifestyle anymore they're gonna hate
I've been through that I know from my
personal experiences when I wanted to
enlighten myself to what in the world is
this life about what's the
purpose of life there's got to be more
than just the after party in the party
making money and then partying on the
weakest has got to be more and I started
to search and I start to ask the one who
created just makes sense if someone
created something you would ask the
owner of that something
how does things work how does this thing
work and what's the purpose of it but
the human body the one who created us
that's where you got to start and I
started to ask and then I start to
investigate and to really use this gift
that the Almighty has given us and
research and look into all the other
religions and and I found that I mean
subhanAllah
that this way of life that you're
looking into Islam it's provided all the
rational logical evidence is based on an
authentic book a believable message and
then I start to share it I used to go
back and people look at you like you're
an alien whoa you're the one is that's
leaving this played-out lifestyle behind
you want more substance you want
substance in your life so don't give up
you're gonna have to make a change of
friends a change of atmosphere and
continue to persevere forward and know
that you and others like you you put up
with all the side effects to the alcohol
nasty hangovers and you kept going back
to that it was tough right I know how
many pills you had to pop to get over
that ailment to that side effect to that
from the drugs and then people
criticizing you backbiting against you
dealing unfairly maybe with your family
and all of the other things the
promiscuity and jumping from this
relationship to that one all the trauma
and disobeying your parents disobeying
God living people living a lifestyle a
challenging tough lifestyle that just
goes heavy on the soul and all that side
effects today and people keep going back
and they keep putting up with it but now
this is a test there's no side effects
because side effects is you did
something negative that comes as a
result of you going towards something
that's not good for you then you have a
side effect Islam there's no side of it
but you're going to be challenged you're
going to be tested of your sincerity to
see if you're sincere in these decisions
and who you gonna love more the friends
so you stay with them all the way to the
end and you keep going back to them or
the one who created you who fashioned
you who gave you all these blessings in
life so not to make this too long again
this was something fortuitous just
wanted to put this together very quickly
because there's a lot of people out
there who are searching for purpose and
then they get bantered and teased and
ridiculed welcome to the party that's
what it is
that's how it happens but there are good
people I mean if you look at in the
Holly just start from the Hollywood
industry look at Francis Ford let's see
what Francis Ford had to say about the
Quran but if you know the Quran the
first words of the Quran the very first
I believe are something like in the name
of God the gracious and the merciful
praise be to God Lord of the Worlds the
most gracious the most merciful master
of the book of judgment they're saying
graciousness and mercy is what's at
through they repeated it twice in the
first page it's you we worship and you
we ask lead us to the straight path the
path of those you have blessed not those
against whom there is anger over a
misguided so anyone who knows this
beautiful religion this beautiful that
was the height of civilization in the
13th century the Arab civilization that
we had that gave us mathematics and
science everyone knows that at the root
of that religion the two most important
words are then God is gracious and God
is merciful and we trust to that God to
deliver us from this
misunderstanding that is doing these
terrible things that has hurt or hurting
people God does not want people to be
hurt God is gracious God is merciful and
that's what I have to say wasn't that
wonderful and this is a another
Hollywood superstar some consider him a
legend look at Harvard University
honoring honoring the Quran by
recognizing one of the chapters chapter
4:1 first one chapter 4 verse 135 as the
greatest expression of justice you're
gonna have this in America in the top
university in America the Koran for
those who want to bring up all of this
nonsense that Islam oppresses that is
unjust but the most prestigious
university in America honors the Quran
by establishing this verse as the
greatest expression of justice wow
that's deep so these are some things
that you probably probably didn't know
so continue to to get to know the Quran
and for all those people again who are
seeking to know purpose you will find it
in this book did you know that the Quran
is the only book on the face of the
earth now that we have that Stamper free
tamper-proof that is a living miracle
that's the only book that's if you were
to throw all of the other books out into
the ocean Birnam lock them up the quran'
is the only book that you can bring back
because it's been memorized by millions
living today it's an authentic book that
has been preserved that has a challenge
in it challenging you the reader that if
you feel that you if you say this is not
from the Quran do such and such and such
because it's making a statement a bold
statement not only challenging you but
also making the claim that the one
revealing this book the Quran is the
creator of the heavens and earth there's
no book like it no book out there
that explicitly states that it's from
the creator of mankind in Arabic Allah
and aramaic ilaha that steep that's
profound
not only lindsay lohan through time
through establishing and other people
who who established this quran in their
lives living by it establishing all of
the things i mean there's there are
about six thousand two hundred thirty
six 6236 verses in the quran and only
around eighty deal with the penal system
so most people they get thrown off they
get misinformation and this is another
topic we talk about a lot of these
things the misinformation verses quoted
out of context but now if someone walks
away having better character becoming a
better human being from this book and
that's the initial goal of islam to make
you rise to your full potential
potential as a human being
so not only does it talk about morality
manners cleanliness charity not only
charity but the eradication of poverty
prayer respect of parents women's be
women being the twin halves of men it
talks about the future was to come the
day of judgment paradise hellfire like
no other book giving a detailed
description of a your creator be the
purpose of life see the day of judgment
that wouldn't make sense that would make
set that doesn't make sense that you
would live life and all of the
oppressors all of the people who have
got gotten away with horrific crime just
picked yourself watching a movie and you
had the most evil villain that you're
just rooting for at the end
he's gonna be brought to justice and at
the end he got away with murder rape and
all sorts of atrocities what kind of
movie would this be what about life
that's it we just you're just an
accident that happened like some people
claim use the accident purpose less no
doc on God teaches us that we're
purposeful we've been created for a
purpose and the Quran establishes what
our purpose in life is where you're
going that there's light at the end of
the tunnel that this life is a test and
while you're here you recognize that
there's only one God that you worship
Him alone not his creation and that you
learn you know God you love God and you
establish that in truth by obedience to
your Creator all of these wonderful
concepts are there in Islam so to
continue on in short Thomas Jefferson
had a Koran so many intellectuals read
this book at the end
you ought to yourself to at least read
this book there are gonna be people who
banter and tease there gonna be people
who hate but at the end of the day the
party will end you're gonna be by
yourself when everybody when the lights
are out and there's no one else around
it's just you that's how it's gonna be
in the grave it's just gonna be you and
now what did you do to prepare for that
meeting that you're gonna have in the
grave that's what really motivated me to
think to ponder there's got to be more
than me just turning to dust and bones
there's got to be a purpose and I often
say if you ended up on the moon you want
to know why in the world you were on the
moon and then you can enjoy the other
things that are on the moon just like
the beautiful things that are on this
earth so the Quran calls us to good to
wonderful things there are things that
people quote
ignorant people who think they know jack
and as I gave you the example earlier
they talked about Jack they gossip about
Jack at the poker table but they never
sat with Jack they never ate with Jack
they don't know jack
so you want to establish a connection
with a Muslim before you talk maybe
visit I'll give you some things to do
visit a mosque if you're someone like
Lindsey and you're curious to know
establish the connection before you go
off following ignorant people who are
out there bashing Islam just like the
may I was doing example bashing Jack who
don't know jack people bashing Islam
don't know it's not get to know a Muslim
go to a to a mosque ask your questions
and then make an informed decision
very simple instead of wasting your
energy and breath cursing acting lewd
like a lunatic expressing and
personifying hate making your heart hard
bitter you just hurting yourself because
no matter how much you spit at the Sun
it's gonna still shine so and if you
can't even do that if you can't even do
that call us
be sincere and within yourself asked the
one who created creation the reality
guide me this is us place to start and
start putting aside time to research to
grow and to realize that everything
around us is gonna pass it's in the past
tense we're gonna leave all of this all
of this behind and I'll leave you the
successful person who that person is I'm
gonna share with you a verse from the
verbatim Word of God the Quran then
we'll conclude how's that
Kunlun F's in the echo to remote the
Quran is preserved in Arabic I'm not an
Arab but that's one of the miracles of
it it says every soul will taste death
and only on the day of judgment and the
day of assembly will you receive your
full payback people been harmed people
been oppressed people been doing good
why are things upside-down the way they
are but when you know look this virus
gives you that confidence that on the
day of judgment the criminals will be
punished and the doers of good will be
rewarded the one who was saved from the
Hellfire from the fire and who was
admitted into the garden into paradise
will have achieve the ultimate reward
the ultimate purpose that is success to
be saved from the Hellfire and to be
emitted in to the paradise rewarded on
that day of judgment the life of this
world is nothing more than material
gains and illusions think about that
ponder about that reflect and ask
because when you ask you shall receive
so ask the one who created you who's
given you all of these blessings to
guide you to guide your heart to what
the purpose of life is and I gave you
those recommendations call us if you
can't visit us and make the connection
for God's sake it's not that difficult
is not that hard and it's much better
than hating that takes a
a lot more stress a lot more anxiety and
it's a lot harder on your heart thank
you and continue to tune in to the Dean
show every week thank you very much
Salaam alaikum peace be with you